rozier
off balance score the goal
terry's taking over and then going at my
high loop on this
offensive end of the floor and rozier
went
downhill aggressively through the right
arm up got the contact to separation
and off the glass look mahalo he's
already beat as he's in retreat mode
look at that tough angle by rozier man
dwayne casey wishing on a falling star
he's actually going to challenge this
dell what
he thinks there wasn't a foul well
can't take it with you that's right we
like dwayne casey doesn't make too many
missteps
but i think you're gonna lose this terry
has been the truth terry rozier
why don't you have a last two minutes
detroit
needs to get a stop and get the ball
back hornets need one more field goal
and they could
pretty much ice it
i want to try and get it to rozier now
he has it only two on the shot clock
terry again
terry's dominating winning time
chairman likes it that's what he came to
see
hornets lead by five virtually
exclusively
on the back of terry rozier you got a
guy like rozier playing like he is right
here
it's not hard to figure out what to do
you use time and score get the ball of
rozier look at how good is he
at creating contact and shooting off
balance fadeaway runners look at him
kept that ball protected get it out
it's almost like a jump shot i think
it's wayne casey stealing that challenge
that would have been a better chance to
challenge that one in the one before
you're right partner you're right roger
may have gotten off with
gotta wait a little push-off but i'm not
complaining
hornets lead by five and